joining us now the former quarterback
number two overall pick 1998 draft Ryan
Leaf friend of the show
good to see you look like you're playing
shape losing weight what's going on here
I got engaged oh so you got to get in
wedding shape I have to get in wedding
shape she said I have five years so that
gives me plenty of time right so long
engagement dude yeah I have a sneaky
suspicion he'll probably happen before
then though okay yeah are we invited
of course okay it's kind of awkward that
I had to ask if we're invited well I
didn't even know invitations are going
out yet she's still trying to decide if
it's gonna be a mountain wedding I want
a destination wedding like on a beach
somewhere where the people can come and
enjoy the event but I bet it ends up
being like in the mountains we could
have it at our man cave and you could
you know there's golf there and we could
get Buffalo Wild Wings to cater there's
beer on tap we would have to probably
cover up the wall of morale those are
the bridesmaids hey she may be open to
that you you've seen her you can ask a
couple of things here you know we're at
the NFL experience and we were we were
joking about this but I'm not joking
about this what if you allowed people
fans to understand what the concussion
protocol is so you allowed them to take
the baseline test to understand what is
asked of these players on the sidelines
how do you think that would that be a
learning experience I bet it would I
think it would be kind of interesting to
do the baseline and then have them run
down to the end of the event and spin
around on a bat a bunch of times like
people do on the dizzy test yeah then
come back and do the test after that
that might give them a sense of what a
concussion may feel like at least
vertigo eyes maybe Walker's through what
what questions are you asked well they
have a list of the things that they have
asked you previously there for me it was
mostly questions that I would have known
from years back long-term memory type of
things and then they asked you those
immediately the biggest things are
what's the day where you at what city
who's the president those you'll get all
those right I don't even remember being
asked the question so
no you were concussed yeah so there
wasn't there wasn't many of those that I
can remember you just did whatever you
could to get back and then they used to
you know the ammonia packets yeah you'd
snap those and just you know and wake
you up that's I watch guys do it before
the games I saw dakki with the other day
do you guys notice that and he snapped
it and the game even starts that's
horrible should use me to that to I used
to do that a lot to to just wake you up
huh speaking of a young quarterbacks
with Jared golf on a couple of weeks ago
and he said that he's glad he sat he
needed to that he wasn't ready and it
seems that you're either all-in or
you're not if you man you've said before
if you sat you know might have helped
you absorb a little bit more it you know
dak Prescott is able to play right away
we've seen guys who come in and play
right away course in ones plays right
away how do you differentiate between
who should and who shouldn't start well
I think the team chemistry I think if
you look at what the Dallas Cowboys have
to offer with that offensive line and
that running back behind him it offered
a good opportunity for him to ease his
way in and learn where LA struggled this
year mightily and it may have been
detrimental to his confidence and his
ability to be a leader here the years
coming up if he would have started from
the get-go should the job in Dallas be
open to Tony Romo I don't see why not I
mean if he's able to perform I just I
love Tony it's just when I just look at
him I look like he's gonna hurt himself
just not even on a football field
sometimes it's just did you know it
every time I saw him slide or land in a
game it looked like he was gonna hurt
himself so I amazing career I think if
he had an opportunity somewhere else you
know that might be I mean
dak has become the leader that football
team and they followed and they did a
tremendous job this year that that
playoff game was pretty amazing
but what would you do if your room oh
I'd probably ask to go someplace else I
think that you may see the writing on
the wall there and you know Jerry Jones
may leverage that situation as far as he
can I mean that's what he does as a
businessman I think he loves the topic I
think he loves talking about well Jerry
likes to talk so what about if you're
Garoppolo would you say to the Patriots
you know well how much yeah how much
longer is he gonna pull
a Tom I mean it seems like the guy can
play til he's 49 yes so that's 10 years
well let's say he plays four more years
I don't know I mean your shelf life as
an NFL football players is very limited
and let's say what are your is this for
Jimmy third I think 34 so let's say
seven years so he'd be seven years in
the league never played rookies gonna
come in and most likely you know he's
gonna be too expensive for a team to pay
so you look at the string of
quarterbacks that have been drafted by
the Patriots who were supposed to be the
next one Ryan Mallett I think was the
biggest you know how to Arkansas and Tom
just outlast them all just keeps
outlasted them all would you rather be
the backup quarterback for the Patriots
or the starting quarterback for the
Browns I figured this out a long time
ago after I left because my pride got in
the way of being a starting quarterback
just to be in the NFL is a privilege so
I would be the backup quarterback
anywhere I'd be the starting quarterback
anywhere if I could just be a
quarterback at the NFL that would be the
privileged enough could you have played
for the Browns this year
hell no get me at all this perspective
now Ryan yeah well that's true clear
head no I know I can read defense as a
heck of a lot better now so who knows
and you move better than Brady does yeah
but he this is a special kind of dance
in there it's it's different what he
does he moves he may not be able to run
in a straight line but he can move in a
box about this big better than the eyes
though because that's what all these
defensive players tell you about Brady
is he will look you in a different
direction
like he'll he'll say I'm gonna I'm over
here I'm not going over here but you
still buy into that it's the experience
I mean he's been in the same offense
from the get-go I ran three offenses in
my first two seasons and he's been doing
this from jump and he's able to know
exactly where his receivers are gonna be
so he can look wherever the heck he
wants to look because he knows where
he's going with the football before he
asked to he he can toy with those
defensive players all he wants
Ryan joins us he just talked about this
quite a few times when he's been on the
show transcend recovery community and
you can actually contact Ryan directly
on Twitter at Ryan deed leaf and it's a
focused intensity foundation explain
what that is though yeah this is of
course we've talked about tramps and
recovery community every time I've been
on here if you are in need right now a
family member yourself please reach out
transcend our c-calm and we'll find a
place for you drugs alcohol drugs
alcohol substance abuse mental health
anything will refer you to a place that
needs to be done the focused intensity
foundation was something I started in
2011 and it was to raise money for
scholarships for people who can't afford
substance abuse or mental health
treatment I relapsed in 2012 so that
foundation essentially should have went
by the wayside but my father knew what
that meant he just knew I wasn't ready
to lead it and while I was in prison
that whole time he kept it alive paying
attorneys fees keeping the 501c3 status
so when he knew I was ready he gave it
back to me and we've started doing it
again and I don't want anybody ever
who needs and wants and accepts help not
to be able to afford it because I
wouldn't have been able to go to
treatment unless the NFL grant program
paid for it for me so I understand what
that feels like and my dad gave me a
great gift in fact he's the biggest
single donor to the foundation that to
this point it's for more information
it's focused intensity foundation it's
focused intensity org or Twitter at Ryan
D Leaf it's always great to see it I
hope people respond to this I know you
get great response when you're on our
program and good luck with the wedding
we're ready to go all right the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]